Hello, oh my gosh, I sound like a dying cat right now.
Hello, hello, hello, everybody.
I just, I literally actually just woke up at 1220.
So I was like, oh, I was like, okay, brush teeth, brush teeth, turn PC on.
Heat food, get PC on.
uh so been um i'm like all over the place right now my mind is still turning on right now um it is uh still revving up it's like i'm rubbing the engine at the moment so my mind is very very very slow because i'm still waking up um anyway good morning everyone sorry i had to do a little pop good morning everyone for those oh here's a little Laura for those who are new here um I don't burp instead of burping I do a pop I don't know why I I think like um I think because like my parents um were like burping is very rude and disgusting so because of that and I also personally was like oh burping is also like oh burping sounds gross so I taught myself at a very like burping i expel my gases by popping so if you ever hear me go like that that's my burp i don't i don't know i i don't know how i don't know how i train my body to do that uh so if you ever heard me do little pops and so that's just me expelling gas uh no it works yes I have not burped in years.
That doesn't sound healthy.
I don't know.
It's like when you're, you know, when you're younger, you're like, okay, also like when I was younger, this was not like something my parents made me think.
I just thought that sneezing was also really great.
gross so when i was younger i would hold my nose and then so i wouldn't do like and then because like i didn't want like expel the the the mucus and stuff everywhere so i would hold my nose when i sneeze when i was younger but that's really that's actually really bad for you no that is really bad for and i stopped when i got older i stopped doing it because i was like wait that's so bad
But when I was younger, when I was younger, I used to do that because I was like, ooh, I don't want to get mucus all over my hands or like I don't want to get mucus like all over my face and everything.
So, so I used to do that a lot when I was a little kid.
But I now, obviously, when I got older, I was thinking, wait, isn't that bad for my body?
And then I just like, I embraced my sneezes.
I will never embrace my burps.
I, like, no, that's banished from Doki Land.
That is outlawed in my world.
And I think pops are just a lot cuter in general in terms of, like, for me, I just think pops are just a lot better.
Like, it's just more, for me, it's like, that's right.
burping wise that's wrong that ain't right that's disgusting get out of here i mean you guys can for me i just think me burping is like just like i just find me burping is just pretty good so that's why i don't do it um and i just uh and i just trained my body to just go pop pop um anyway What was I gonna,
uh, uh, what was I, I mean, it's your, your body.
I don't control your body.
If I could, I would, but if I, if I could pass a law where burping is outlawed, I would, but obviously I can't do that.
Because, oh, Doki, that's so, that's wrong.
That's like being a dictator, apparently.
Even though I just want what's right for your body.
But, oh, apparently I'm a bad guy for trying to control burping.
Literally 1984.
Anyway.
We are going to be playing Hollow Knight today.
And this is actually...
Sorry if I'm a brainer.
So maybe if I'm like stumbling on words today.
Or like struggling to find...
words right now because I am uh I am EP it takes me like one hour to warm up my my brain uh but anyway we're gonna be playing Hollow Knight today and this is actually my very first time ever playing a true Metrovania I never grew up with Metroid like I said because I never grew up with Nintendo games other than Pokemon because uh my dad was like uh Nintendo's are for pussies so I I never grew up with like any Metro type games.
Never played Hololight because I think when Hololight came out, I was either, I don't remember when Hololight, okay, when Hololight came out, but I think either I was too busy with my studies back then before I got, um, before I got sucked back into gaming,
or it was when, um, it was when I was only playing multiplayer games.
So I never played Hololight and then everyone always judges me for never, having never experiencing hollow night um by that time oh 2017 i don't even remember i don't remember where i was at at that time because either i was too busy playing multiplayer games or i was too busy studying it was one or the other um and i said and then in my chat you guys me chaguns were like yoki when will you ever play hollow night and then i laughed at you guys and was like whenever silk song announces the release date because i thought you know that would be like I don't know seven more years you know I'd say that I would throw that statement everywhere I go like what about holiday and I'm like ha ha whenever silk song announces a release date you know it's like oh whenever pigs fly and and and then last week they announced the release date and it would be like and silk sock releases next week so you know i would i thought you know um i would have much more time to play holo night because i looked up
how long to complete holo night and then they're like you know if you're like almost an optimal gamer who has experience with metrovania it would take you around 27 hours So then I was thinking, all right, if we convert the 27 hours into Doki hours, that would be like 40 hours,
maybe.
So, because I'm like, what's the conversion of regular gamer hours to Doki hours?
So I'm just like, okay, we're not finishing Hollow Knight before Silk Song releases.
So, what I'm planning on doing is, what I'm planning on doing is that we're going to play Hollow Knight, and in the day Silksaw releases, we'll play Silksaw on launch, and then we go back to Hollow Knight, and then continue part two of Silksaw whenever I finish Hollow Knight,
but I still, I still want to play Silksaw on release, just so, so at least I'll like have the the whole night experience and then um and then like we go in and then we just go back like it's just like you know just just have a glimpse of the future for a little bit you know when your time travel forward to see like what's the future like and then go back and then nothing changes in the future because um it relies on the past uh so things will be fine
Spoiled?
Spoiled on what?
Like, it doesn't, man.
It's fine.
Like, I feel like I won't even understand.
Like, I'll look at it, and then I'll be like, I'll be like, I don't, I'll look at, it'll be even better, because then when I get to that part, in Hollow Knight, I'll be like, I'll be like, oh, so that's what it meant in Silk Song.
It's okay.
Everything will be fine.
won't even understand if I do get spoiled.
If we convert it to Doki, the Doki brain, it will most likely mean I just won't understand if I do get spoiled in the sequel.
It's the Doki logic.
Crippy, they gave it a super chat, thank you, thank you.
super random question.
I'm going to get my nails done for Vexpo next week in your colors.
I was just wondering what pattern the colors are in.
Wait, what pattern the colors are in?
You mean like, I mean, go wild.
You just do like my main outfit and just go wild.
I'm pretty sure it's going to look amazing in general.
And I bet you're, I bet it's going to be like super creative.
I guess, I mean, it was for my normal.
I love nail art.
Nail art is very...
I don't like getting my nails done, but I love looking at nail art.
The reason why I don't like getting my nails done is that it is, it looks very...
It is painful and it looks very painful.
So because you know how you're like scraping under...
For those who never got their nails done, for the people out there that don't get their nails done, um you know how they have to like scrape underneath the uh the nail they have to scrape underneath the skin where your nails connect to your finger and clean it and that's also how they and they like insert it under your skin a little bit um and that is so scary yeah the the cuticle yeah and yeah so like some nails they do that so that's why like I don't get my nails done like I've done it once and I was like no
but but you get pretty nails
you get but the nails are really pretty um and and because of that um I love looking at it like power to you guys um for able to do it but power to you but I don't even get my ears pierced so um because I was I've been really okay the reason why I don't get my ears pierced is one I'm always scared of the pain of uh of them um of them like putting a hole in my ear to ear infections.
I always hear horror stories of my friends getting ear infections from like a bad earring or something or something just going, getting into the hole.
And so I was like, I do not want to, I don't want to go through that.
And apparently it's like, it's so painful too when you have an ear infection where the piercing is.
So yeah, and they close up too.
So you have to like punch a hole in it again.
get my ears pierced um and that is also why like i don't get my nails done because if i can't fucking handle ear piercings i cannot handle them fucking sticking under my nails like i can't i can't handle that i yeah so a little fun fact for those people who don't get their nails done and when you see all those pretty nails they went those those women went through went through a lot to make them look pretty and they're also very expensive too and another reason is also like they're more fragile yeah i mean i mean you could just use clip-ons but they're not the same it's not the same but um um but um and when you if you have like the real real like the you know the real nails getting done where it's literally in your fingers in your fucking fingers um and the longer too you know you know how like the nails are longer uh so if your nail gets caught on something
it is not okay new nightmare unlock yeah if your nail gets caught on something it's in your finger just that
Yeah, so that's why can't we shut up you like my nail now
Because the reason why I'm like I fear that a lot is because it happened to my mom once I was I was seven
So now I have to live through that trauma, guys.
It's been years, and I still think about it.
I was seven when that happened.
So now I have to live through that trauma, the generational trauma of like never getting my nails done.
I witnessed it.
I got it done once.
That was enough for me.
Why are you making us suffer with you?
So you can live with that fear, too.
Because I was safe from...
I'm just trying to make you guys safe, guys.
I'm just trying to give you guys safety advice.
It's like how...
The reason why we have insane fear of...
The reason why like some of us have like phobias or like fear of like, you know, when you're young, you're like, why do you fear spiders?
Even though, you know, if you never encountered a spider or like a snake or something, then as a baby, but you're still fear it is because like millions, I don't know, hundreds of thousands of years ago, our ancestors were instilled that fear in us because they would kill us because it's survival of the fittest,
like the instinct, you know, these animals would actually kill us so that fear is like instilled into us so i'm instilling this fear onto you guys for your safety it's survival of the fittest i'm trying to give make you feel safe
um but yeah anyway um okay what okay minutes all right i was gonna give you guys another story time but i realized it's hollow night time we gotta get as much done as possible uh i tell you this because i want you to be safe it's like i'm like that that character from rapunza where i lock you up in the tower and be like don't worry nothing will hurt you now a healthy community has the same lifetime trauma Exactly.
Thank you for the super chat, Maddie.
Thank you.
All right.
It's hallowed night time.
I'm just looking out for you guys.
But yeah, honestly, like, you guys, like, people who don't get their nails, someone never know that it's actually in your nails.
You think like they're just like, oh, you're just painting.
You're just like painting your nails into these beautiful nail art.
You're painting it on like, you're not painting it on your actual nail.
You're painting it on like a little acrylic thing And then you're inserting it into your finger.
That shit is hardcore.
Why do you keep talking about?
It's that?
No, no, it's not actually on your finger the nail art Is on an acrylic and then they insert it in your finger
So stop talking about it's not core.
It's just getting your nails done.
That's what it means when women are like, I'm going to get my nails done.
Like, bro.
Like, okay, played the game.
All right.
That's it.
I'm getting me mad at that.
Happy thank you for the super chat, thank you, thank you.
Gourum, my comfort nails.
All right, oh wait, do I need a, let me look at the settings real quick.
Let's see, show achievement.
No, we don't need that audio.
All right, sound guy.
You enjoy talking about certain, I like putting, I mean, I've never had issues with putting contact lenses on or taking them off.
It's just, oh, that's it.
I never had any issues about Ovid growing up.
I don't even have to look in the mirror.
I can just take it out without having to look in the mirror.
Like, I just, I don't know.
I just know where it is.
Alright, let's see.
I just want to make sure I got everything in.
Particle Explorer quality.
Low.
Frame rate cap.
What is the cap, though?
That's fine.
It's not an FPS.
I don't really have to worry.
Okay, we're going to use controller.
Alright, sound guy.
Let me know if everything's okay for sound.
Alright, start game.
I actually have no idea what the story is for Hollow Knight.
I just know they're all bugs.
That's everything I know about Hollow Knight.
They're all just bugs.
in wilds beyond they speak your name with reverence and regret for none could tame our savage souls yet you challenge yet you the challenge meant under palace watch you taught we change based instance were redeemed a world you give to bug and beasts as they had never dreamed i love poetry um when i was younger uh when i was younger um i would do like uh there would be like poetry You read up poems to the class slash school,
and I love doing that.
Because you have to be so expressive with poetry.
I hate writing poetry, though.
I just love reading it.
I always, like, I always participate in any, like, poetry reading contest.
As a kid.
When I got older, I just started hating it.
I just, like, stopped reading, I guess.
It's a bit loud.
I just stopped reading when I was older.
When I got older.
My favorite poem.
I'm trying to remember.
They're very childish.
A lot of my favorite poems are very childish poems.
Because, you know, I like...
I was reading poetry when I was...
was like, in first to fourth grade.
Yay!
That's me!
I'm John Hollow Knight.
Does it, will it give me instructions later?
Yeah.
I know this is from the fame rate cap or anything.
Trying to see if I'm lagging at all.
Okay.
All right.
I'm John Knight.
Oh, she's actually playing Hollow Knight.
What's that supposed to mean?
Yes, I...
What?
It's on my waiting room.
Of course it's on.
I'm actually playing Hollow Knight.
What else would I be playing?
What?
these words are for you alone your great strength marks you amongst us focus your soul and you shall achieve feats of which others can only dream let's soul by striking anyone's enough soul hold b to focus so oh it's to heal i don't need a heal yet all right okay i mean i don't need a heal so it's fine oh because it's a metrovania um i can go anywhere i want right i assume that's what oh my god what the fuck hit me okay there's no follow damage that's good i'm in the line of bugs it's like bugs life like now i can focus uh and turn down the music okay i'll turn it down let me know if it's better yeah what makes the metrovania metrovania anyway it does feel okay let me actually adjust the frame so i'm gonna do uncapped uh because It does feel just a little bit.
Maybe it's...
Oh.
Okay.
It's literally, like, full screen.
I'm going to put it on full screen.
It does...
Oh, my God.
I can't...
Okay, there we go.
Yes.
Wait, no.
No.
Go to full screen.
Why does it keep jumping?
Full screen.
Oh, my God.
Okay.
Full screen.
Why?
Why can't I play on full screen?
Full screen.
Why?
It's forcing me off.
It's actually forcing me off of full screen.
Every time I put it on full screen, it's like, do you mean borderless?
No!
I mean, full...
Okay, never mind.
It's not letting me play full screen, guys.
why i i i don't know why it it's i i don't know why it's i i don't know why it's actually forcing itself off of four full screen that's crazy it's it's like physically not allowing me to play on full screen every time i put it on they're like no okay there you go we fixed okay there we did it oh my god no you don't understand the game itself was like please please I did not consent to be played on full screen stop it was actually fighting against me holy fuck that was crazy like someone stop her she's forced me on full screen.
Are we trying FrameCat back on?
It feels more fluid, though.
I don't know.
Where am I?
So what makes a Metro... Yeah, I beat the first boss, guys.
What makes it a Metrovania?
Metrovania.
I've never played one before, so I don't really know that genre.
I'm just gonna vandalize everything, I guess.
Harry Beans, these words are for you alone.
on this point you enter uh the land of king and creator step across this threshold and obey our laws bd platform with lots of zones everything is connected oh so it's just backtracking all right guys it's time to um on this playthrough maybe we'll finally learn how to read a map because like i feel like if i don't like we're the 40 hour prediction might turn into a 60 hour prediction
There was the last and only civilization, the eternal kingdom, Holonest.
Oh, is that my house?
Since I am John Holonite?
Am I the prince of Holonest?
I, dokey, I consent, computer, I consent, game.
I don't, isn't there someone you forgot to ask?
JL, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Let's leave, oh, okay.
Wait, can I just...
okay yeah i was like just just go for it see zero survival instinct i was like i don't have fall damage right i'm just i'm just like i just fully trusted that i would live hello where are the people dirt mouth the fading town where are the people at hello
there's only me left to offer welcome our towns falling quiet you see oh my god you're like you're like lonely george that turtle someone quit give we gotta repopulate the world the other residents they all disappeared headed down that well one by one into the caverns below used to be there was a great cat kingdom beneath our town it's long fell to ruin yet it still With the lower enlightenment,
that darkness seemed to promise all things.
I'm sure you too seek your dreams down there.
Well, watch out.
It's a sticky air that fills the place.
Creatures turn mad and travelers are robbed of their memories.
Perhaps dreams aren't such great things after all.
Oh hey, let's rest.
I guess that's like a safe point, right?
A safe point slash yeah?
Keep him company.
And it's fine, he can just die alone.
For all your mapping supplies, we will be opening soon.
Okay.
You think they'll open, guys?
Oh, there's the well.
What if I don't go there?
What's over here?
Are these bug graves?
That's right, vandalizing.
Vandalism.
A stone door with a simple lock.
All right.
Will I be able to dash soon?
Unless dashing is, like, an ability I earn later.
Alright.
Down the way I go.
I don't want to be alone with lonely George.
Okay.
Forgotten crossroads.
I'm a menace to society.
Wait, am I a bad person?
Like, all these people are just existing.
Wait.
I like I don't know they don't seem to be bothering me and I'm like fuck you I don't like your kind like yeah maybe because I'm thinking like wait like what did they do to me why am I murdering all these bugs like I literally spawn in Just a murder.
Me.
I feel like I literally I spawn in just to kill them.
Alright.
Yeah.
I got hurt them before they hurt me.
You don't understand.
Like how they make little poop noises.
When they die.
Because like you know when you're dead.
Oh, I can't do that yet.
I can't wall jump when you when you die like you expel everything out So it's just like real life They're buying Yeah, it's like when you Um, it's like okay, so There's also another fear of mine
Um, but it's also for those here's a little fun fact guys.
I told this fun fact before but for all these new people We did consent to this fun fact.
When you give birth, you poop a little.
Because you're pushing.
That's not very fun.
Yeah, do not again.
What are you?
I guess you're going to be stuck there for the rest of your life.
Because I can't, I haven't learned how to dash yet.
Somebody take away her full screen windows.
My wife just had a baby.
I can confirm it is true.
Is that common knowledge?
No, it's not.
So yeah, they all see you pooping.
little when you give birth all right okay i'm just tanking it i shouldn't just be tanking it i'm literally i'm just running it i'm like i don't care you guys mean you guys do nothing to me i should really i should really start dodging it doesn't matter i can just self-heal it for now the exactly the miracle of childbirth
All right, nice.
Oh, there's a thing pointing down.
But let me see what's over here first.
All right, nice.
Okay, where's my map?
Do I get to see where my map is at any point?
Down I go.
I don't know where I am.
Oh, a bako.
I can't go there yet.
You have to find him?
Oh my god, there's the Metroid in my Metrovania.
Oh my god, please, go up.
John Hollow Knight, go up.
I need, like, a dash in the map.
What's this?
Oh, that seems nice.
Hello.
Oh!
I'm sorry, I was giving you a love tap.
I didn't know!
I was just trying to give you a love tap!
Okay.
I don't fucking know.
I'm just...
Tap.
See, he likes it.
He's giving me a love tap in return.
That can't be a boss.
He just won...
Yeah, exactly.
I'm giving him some taps.
she's crazy I just shimmy back guys that's not yes please you know what I did when I fought him I went right and then I went left yeah that has to be just a big that kid does not feel like a boss fight oh oh my god joking gaming and then I get hit by him.
The smaller they are, the harder it is, apparently for me.
You know what?
This game is so easy.
Look at that.
Okay.
I think that's like the pattern to kill for them.
It's just you go left and then you go right.
And then occasionally you do a little jump too.
You feel a little quirky.
Hello.
Anybody here?
I'll listen to you.
you hello there how delightful delightful to me another traveler on these forgotten roads wait he doesn't lonely george doesn't have to be lonely anywhere quick go up there and repopulate the surface world how delightful to me a lot of traveler on these you're a short one but you're strong you have a strong look with you i'm coral i have something of a deception obsession with uncharted places the ancient kingdom holds many fascinating mysteries and one of the most right before it stand right before us a great stone egg laying the corpse of an ancient kingdom and this egg is it worn it certainly gives off a unique air can it be open there are strange marks all over it I do so love a mystery and who knows what other Marvel lies even deeper below us oh what egg is that is that is What am I fucking fucked up if a bird hatches out of that and just eats everyone in the town of Hollow Knight?
Now that's the Hollow Knight I want.
A giant bird just hatches and just eats everybody.
Yeah, but it's because like what other egg would it be?
There's no way these bugs can make an egg that big.
Never right again.
Ascend.
Oh.
I'm outside now.
Oh, I went back.
Oh, I came back from my Metrovania.
Okay, I guess that means I go left now.
Or did I go left last time?
I'm already lost, guys.
I don't remember where I was.
I don't remember where have I been.
Alright.
Oh, I should heal.
I need to pay attention to my health.
Who's that?
Oh, hello.
I found your kid.
That'll be $20.
Oh, wait.
Oh, my God.
Thank you.
Yay.
I'm sorry.
I said $20.
Not 10.
Or you'll never see the rest of your children again.
That's right.
I'm extorting you.
Dude, no, he gave me, he's, he gave me $10 short.
I don't remember what that word, oh wait, he did give me, sorry, sorry sir, wait, sorry, sir, I didn't mean that, I just, I can't count.
Sorry, you did give me, you did give me a 20.
Sorry, sir, but if you fuck with me again, You will not see your other sons.
I'll put him back in the jar and I won't poke air holes.
Where are your sounds?
Okay, not those ones, but the po-po-po-po-po-po-po.
What's that word called when like they they uh purposely Didn't give you the right amount of cash?
What's the mob?
What's the gangster term?
Oh, I die, die.
I thought I could...
Short-changing.
It's...
Oh, I already did this area.
Because he's not...
He's not happy anymore.
Oh, yeah.
They short me on cash.
They're trying to stiff me.
I wonder if they come back.
Where the fuck is the map guy?
Oh, map guy?
Oh, that has to be in the map guy.
Look, he has all the...
He's a nerd.
Hello there.
Um, wait.
Come down to explore these beautiful older ones.
Don't mind me.
I have a fondness for exploring myself.
Getting lost and finding a way again is a pleasure like no other.
We're quizzically lucky you are not.
I'm a photographer, buddy.
church and i'm working on mapping this area right now would you like to buy a copy of my work so far
he's a married man leave him alone he's a nerd lv to view a map okay
show you where you are.
If you're not the head for directions, I suggest purchasing a compass from my wife, Azelta.
She's now opening a new map shop in Dirt Mounds, sharing all sorts of useful things to wanderers like yourself.
No, you didn't sell some of my old maps from town at the time.
I'll pop back to see her whenever I finish mapping an area.
She's always so excited to see me.
That nerd is less single than you are.
All right, we'll be the judge of how hot his wife is.
We'll be the judge of the hotness of the wife.
The moment I figure out how to get out of here.
Ow.
What?
He has a wife for now.
Okay.
Oh, I'm just killing her and her babies.
I don't know.
I feel like I'm a bad person.
Am I not?
Hello.
Nice.
Another $20 for my paycheck.
Alright.
Yeah.
Whoops.
Oh, it gives me a... Okay, I was trying to see if there's a speedrun tech where, like, if I fall closer to the other platform, It just takes me there.
That's a paycheck right there.
Okay, I obviously...
I need, like, a double jump for that.
Wait.
How do I look at...
Where am I?
Which one's me?
Which one...
Where am I?
Am I on this map?
This doesn't even look like...
me but i got scabbed give me a real fucking map oh i don't have a comfort oh that you scared me my name is current coroner free and i've always jealous showing the world when i first touch i wonder what i mean to be moving my brothers and sisters and poor mother behind yes as soon as i could i looked at their mouth with my wife a huge unending kingdom to explore right on the doorstep who could resist anyway help me let you return to your troubles with a little echo queen again be safe and farewell oh yeah i just saw sound yeah i said uh lower music and sound by one all right okay all right this is lander all right so i have to oh i have to go Where am I?
Okay, so I had to go to his wife to buy a compass so I know where I am.
I have to figure out how to get to that area.
Okay, I think it's above me, I'm pretty sure.
And I can kill these guys again for free money.
Because I spent it on Darth Maul.
Or not Darth Maul.
I spent it on this stupid scam of a map.
This map doesn't even tell me where I am.
Where's the you are here, Marky?
Oh, oh, I need double- I need Dash for that to save him.
That's my $20 paycheck right there.
Yeah?
What the fuck is it?
Yeah, I need to go up.
I need to go to the surface world for my compass.
But I need to figure out how to get to the surface world.
Okay, this is not how.
I'm so lost.
I don't need to go out and ask for directions, Laura.
Ask the locals, come on, do you ask the locals for directions?
No, I can figure this out.
This is my car, and I will figure it out.
Where am I?
If I look at it a little harder, I'll know where I am.
Just give me a sec.
Okay, maybe this way.
Well, okay.
Okay, maybe it's up top.
Maybe it's like the other door.
Oh my god, let me...
These enemies are so annoying.
This is why I tank it.
Okay, not.
Not now!
Okay.
It'd be like here.
You said it.
Is this where...
Here it is?
Oh, there it is.
See, I told you I can figure it out.
Alright, now to judge how hot the wife is.
Like, like, she lives here.
That's where she lives.
Oh my!
How?
How the fuck did he snag her?
He must...
Like...
Oh my god.
Ma'am, can I...
Do you know where his wife is?
Because, like, obviously it can't be you.
Oh my god.
Maybe he has assets that we were not aware of.
Like...
The nerds got the risk.
I'll come to buy a map, have you?
And certainly my husband used to be dealing with.
But what a surprise.
He's headed down below.
He'll pop back occasionally to deliver new maps for the store.
But I do wish he spends a little more time up here.
I'm not much interested in retailing myself.
Oh, you're...
Are you lonely?
Don't worry, it's Hilda.
I have plenty of time to keep you company.
see what's here for me to sell okay i need oh my gosh i need like 20 more dollars all right give me a second i gotta kill a couple of children down below uh toky what's not my fault his husband's too busy being a nerd i have plenty of time if she's lonely okay nice the money refilled here i'm gonna should be enough you oh my man corny an apology thank you for the super chat odin thank you thank you i ain't apologizing for shit there has to there has to be reasons why she's with and also he is an inattentive husband her his wife is in that story all lonely and sad once company and I'm here to give it to her.
Hello.
Bar Panada.
Alright.
I purchased the compass.
Open the charm menu whilst it resting.
Where the fuck is up?
Oh, the bench is over here.
So in the end, he's the one in the wrong.
Okay.
To equip a charm, press this.
No, it will not be more fun than you.
It will do.
not be more fun.
Thank you for that super chat.
Thank you.
Just because there's a goalkeeper doesn't mean you can't score VLX.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Look, all I'm saying is that she's up there and he's down there.
Yeah, you want the quill too eventually?
Well, I'm broke trying to rob people for money okay oh it doesn't oh going into your screen doesn't uh stop the game that's good to know uh i guys i have 14 i'm not i can't afford that right now all right now i know where i am okay where have i not gone like are any holes that haven't gone yet okay to the left
But like right now I'm broke and I...
Ah!
Fuck.
Right now I'm broke and I'm trying to rob these people for their life savings.
Yeah.
I'm not a bad guy.
I'm just desperate.
A man's gotta do what a man's gotta do.
To steal someone else's woman.
Alright.
The Pilgrim's Raid Travelers of Holiness Descends toward Through verdant wilds and fungal grows To city at the kingdom's heart They all wishes shall be granted All truths revealed You're not evil You're just broke Exactly Beek-a-boo Oh so you're just a pussy Kate Ha ha ha So you're just a fucking pussy?
He's like...
He's like those people that like...
He's like those people that can...
That's like all bark and no bite because at the moment you get close to them they just run away.
And that's not me and I'm not one of those people by the way.
All right, um...
I think there was something down there above me.
I'm trying to remember.
Okay, now there was another area below.
Oh, shit.
That's an accident.
There was, like, another entrance over here.
From what I remember.
Yeah.
Over there.
Okay.
I mean, at least I'm farming money.
Backtracking it.
Just gotta remember.
Figure out how to get there.
God damn it, okay.
Okay, at least I'm getting rid of these guys.
Okay, I jumped from this platform to the next.
Shit, okay, I jumped from this platform to the next.
Yeah.
Okay, guys, get away.
Get away!
Bug be gone!
Oh my god, you mosquito spray right now.
I'm like trying to figure out Okay, here you go.
Ow.
That's fine.
Worth it.
Now where am I?
Oh, wait.
Why doesn't this...
Have I been here before?
No, I have.
God damn it.
What?
Oh, my God.
I just got scammed.
Why is this not...
Oh, my God.
He actually scammed me.
That fucker.
That's...
I okay now I know wait how much is a quill oh my god he sends me he fucking sends me a half finished product and then I have to finish his map for him I have to buy I have to buy a item to finish his own product okay I have to figure out how to fucking get 120 dollars now other than casual murder it was a work in progress it cost me so i gave his family like three hundred dollars
that's like my entire life savings back in pogo oh i should have been doing that wait that's so much easier jk
Never mind.
Like, where are they buying the groceries?
I swear to God, if they're going to that that bougie-ass...
Oh my God, what was that bougie-ass supermarket?
I swear to God.
They better be going to, like, the dollar store so we can make this $300 worth.
Oh, it's him again does he have money wait i think he does i think he sells money okay i think he has a lot of money i'm gonna keep killing him yeah the arwan or whatever the fuck i swear to god they're going to arwan for their fucking groceries and that's why they're scamming me a loyal customer i swear to fucking god all right how much is that that was 45 okay i can farm him
if they're going to trade a jose or iran i swear to fucking god you cannot afford that right now
okay how much was it again because i'm getting there
oh can i come back okay oh if i come back okay 120 okay i it's 120 i'll go back and I'm gonna go back to the entrance then.
What was this again?
I don't remember.
Oh, that's a quarrel.
Uh, if you guys think of this, we're chat.
Thank you.
I've not found...
Uh...
I've not found, like, any benches yet.
Unfortunately.
Alright.
I don't even remember where the kids are.
like where the father was so i can like so i can extort him for more money
like i need my goddamn quill so i can keep extorting all right nice
all right we can go back now at quill time
all right there we go now we have the quill what are the other stuff deep spins will mark benches and other rest spots on your map useful oh my god cornelius did fucking scam me he gave me a 30 map so i have to spend more money on his shop to do his stupid mapping for him like i'm nearly doing this goddamn cartographer job the map dlc he fucking got me with the map dlc the microtransaction The goddamn map microtransaction,
this fucker.
I knew it was too good to be true.
I was like, whoa, $30?
Oh my god.
Thanks, sir.
They got me.
My fucking map DLC microtransaction.
Okay, there's this.
That's where the kids are.
It's just business.
All right.
I gave you, I saved another child $20, please.
Oh shit!
Got my $20.
They got me good.
Alright, where have I not gotten?
I guess like, bottom?
Is it all the way down?
Yeah, it is.
The butt capitalism.
I can't believe it!
Fuck you, Cornelius!
Can never escape capitalism.
Not even in the bug world.
It's truly a bug's life.
Alright, I haven't been here.
But, this is free money.
Oh, shit, secret!
Okay, nice.
This has to be, like, someone's...
Like, they saved...
They...
It took this person 20 years to save up this stash, and I'm just here...
Like, casually robbing them.
All I'm saying is, if this is your life or anything, you should have hit it better.
Not my fault.
They can't hide your money better.
Should have went to that fucking bank.
Not my fault you don't trust the bank.
It's like those people that hide their money underneath their bed mattresses.
But yeah, finders keepers.
It's their home.
It is not their home.
Where is the security?
Wait, what?
Why did it lock me in?
There's the security.
Okay.
Oh.
I killed an entire family.
Yippee.
It's the final boss.
The final countdown.
Kill.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
That's rich come from something that doesn't lock your apartment store.
That's different.
I have a security dog.
As long as it's not a pretty woman, I'm fine.
My dog will do his job.
Did I go here yet?
Yeah, I did.
Okay, now I have $130 back.
Okay.
What's over here?
Oh, they're both at the same entrance.
I like that.
Wait, they're not.
Wait, this is different.
What's over here?
Oh my god, a bench?
Finally.
I feel like I haven't seen the fucking bench in forever.
This is a hot spring?
I should be burning alive.
It is.
Alright.
Am I going the right way?
Wait, give me a sec.
I got killed.
I got to steal his money.
real quick.
Glory, Story, Souls?
Do you mean the white stuff?
I should not call it white stuff.
I need to learn to...
I need to, like, use the Pogo move more.
Because I know...
I feel like that would be, like, super effective in battles.
Oh, shit.
Give me a sec.
Got a chance.
the white stuff.
There is...
I assume there's more money here.
No, it's just people for me to rob.
Which is technically money.
My little piggy banks.
Gotta break open the piggy bank.
What the fuck is that?
Am I fuck?
Like, wait, how do I...
Oh, okay.
Oh, there's a down.
Okay, I see it down.
I didn't see that hole there.
Alright, nice.
Is there anything above me?
Oh, whatever.
I'll just go this way first.
Alright.
I think there's a boss room above me, I assume?
I think, like, I think that looks like a boss room above me.
Knock knock Knock knock Who's here?
Knock knock I'm breaking all your stuff Knock knock Oh, it was just an empty hallway Oh Hello Let me in, let me in, let me in
Well, since you won't let me in I'll just break everything around you I can't wait to get the dash I feel so slow No vandals allowed I'm angry now, I'm gonna break it up.
Oh, ow.
That's rude.
Only I'm allowed to kill.
Okay.
Oh, that restores my...
Oh, that's a soul thing.
Channeling the white stuff is what the map guys wiped.
Broken body.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
it's over here it's a lot of just empty corridors which is what I've noticed wait I got the quill why isn't this like wait a minute
I got the quill why is my DLC not working oh it updates at the bench okay I was gonna say did I swear to God if Cornelia scanned me again I swear to fucking God I swear to God like can I not just draw while I'm walking like I was like I swear to God if you're like you missed out on another DLC we released a new DLC so you can have your map updated at real time I swear to fucking God I
need the ink DLC yeah a door in open slot Oh.
Oh, hey, secret.
Yay!
Still someone else's hidden stash.
And the secret was not as worth it as I thought.
Down here?
Another secret here?
Yeah, that's right.
It's his bug.
Oh, wait.
Is that a boss?
He has a name.
Oh, shit.
Oh, my God.
Oh, okay, that's on me.
I felt bad.
Like, do I hit him?
Oh, no, he'll just stop.
Okay.
I got confused, because I was like, will he stop?
Like, sir, please, if I let you hit me, would you, like, stop doing that?
Sir, this is not healthy.
Sir, please.
Take your anger out on something else.
Or more healthier things.
It's a mother.
It's a she.
Well, I guess then all their kids are gonna be orphans now.
Don't worry.
I'll let you meet your mother.
Guys, I'm not a bad person, right?
Right?
Alright.
dead orphans.
Look, it's survival of the fittest, guys.
It's just...
It's just simply survival of the fittest.
Natural selection.
Those bugs would have died anyway if I didn't intervene.
I'm just making sure they suffer less.
Oh, you wield your nail like a club.
That's me.
How much deeper do we have to go?
Oh, what?
Who are you?
I see this old village.
What a strange dream to have led me down here.
If you hadn't found me, I don't think I've ever woken.
I'm sly.
Usually, I live an uneventful life up in Dirtmouth.
The air in these ruins doesn't create me, so I best be getting back.
You turn above, come and see me.
I'm probably the friendliest face left there.
I can thank you properly for your good deeds.
Alright, nice.
Now the elder has more friends.
If I support someone evil, am I evil?
Lucky for you, you're not supporting any evil person.
Thank you for the super chat, Luke.
Thank you, thank you.
Thank God you're not supporting anyone evil right now.
True.
Yeah, I'm lawful, good.
Wait, did I just kill all the people there?
Oh, there's nothing else here.
Yeah.
I know I haven't been here because all this stuff is still intact.
Wait, I'm... Yeah?
I don't know.
Yeah, there's nothing here.
And this is where...
Where was this again?
No.
I don't remember.
God damn it.
Where the fuck are the benches?
Awfully.
Yeah, awfully good of me.
Right?
You just had a little typo, right again?
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Yep, I didn't get the updates in real time DLC.
God damn.
Fucking scammed.
Okay.
Oh my god.
Stupid children.
your or your dead orphans okay you gotta eliminate everybody in the bloodline so no one will get revenge on you i think the hardest part is just remembering where the benches are because i feel like i only found one bench in this entire run
is there anything yet i know i haven't been here wait i hear something i hear children i here my next paycheck my next extortion and like here what does that do what does that do oh it goes up where am i
where am i oh wait i'm back here oh okay
Wait, I think I can afford the Benchmarkers, which is why, yeah, I need that, actually.
Okay, I'm gonna go get the, buy the Benchmarkers, buy the next DLC.
Okay, I just gotta go up.
Yeah, I can extort the dad later.
Wait, this is not correct?
I'm reading this map route?
No, okay, it's this way.
all right i'll get more it's okay guys i'm just getting the dlc it's this way wait it's this way i have just enough
okay these guys not worth it now since i just have enough for the bench dlc actually no fuck you you hit you were not allowed to touch me so you have to die
all right here i'll go here i'll go where it's almost there oh my god i cannot wait for the dash walking sucks all right all right all right nice i'll need the bench dlc And then, I've seen those maidies, so you can keep... These cocoons are very pretty.
What the fuck is a cocoon?
Marks, shopkeepers, or any other you find on your travels.
Keep track of the...
What does the hot springs do?
Mark interesting spots.
Use markers.
You can use them to mark... Oh, okay.
I guess we'll do the vendor pin.
Oh, they're... Oh, they're temporary...
Okay.
Where are the cocoons, though?
Cancun's do?
Blue stuff?
Oh, they're the temporary HP.
Oh, wait, then what about... Oh, and Hot Springs restore... Oh, Hot Springs restore it all your HP.
Okay, I don't need any of that.
Alright.
And then they said that...
What's his name?
The other guy.
Where's the...
The other guy's Skelly or whatever.
Does he live over here?
Does he live in the graveyard?
That's fucking depressing, bro.
Okay, he doesn't live in the graveyard.
Oh, it's on the left.
I was gonna be like, bro, I know, like, real estate is expensive, but it's pretty depressing to live next to the graveyard.
The other way there.
Oh, he's all the way here.
Okay.
Hello.
Hey, morning.
I know we meet again.
How do you like my cozy little store?
I made myself pretty comfortable here.
Selling old trinkets to travelers.
You're planning a trip below?
I have several items that may improve your chance of survivability.
Okay.
Jesus fucking.
How many DLCs are there?
If I can kill all those bugs and rob them of their life savings, why can't I do that for this guy?
It's just all DLCs.
All right.
Well, I can't afford any of this.
Everyone here wants my money that I worked so hard to earn through murder.
But it's very hard to murder, though.
Guys, I've earned these money through honest means.
You don't understand.
Murder is still very hard to do.
Do I need the egg?
I need the egg.
I...
I never lied that I wasn't committing murder.
Alright, let's go.
I guess we could buy the egg.
That's the only thing I can afford in this goddamn store.
Egg bad?
Wait, what's wrong with this egg?
It was $60.
What's wrong?
Did I get scammed?
Oh, my!
Did you guys?
I trusted you.
I trusted all the...
What the fuck does the egg do?
Okay, but what does it do?
It does nothing.
It's just a rotten egg.
Oh my god.
My $60.
That...
My honest means of living.
I worked so hard to earn the $60.
Where do I go?
I make a look down.
Oh.
I'm so bad at the pogo jump thing.
Never mind.
I'm a fucking jean.
I'm a fucking natural.
JK.
I'm a gaming prodigy.
There we go.
This way.
Okay.
We haven't gone right yet.
We haven't gone into the blowing tunnel yet.
There must be something in here.
Oh, there's a bug here.
Hello, ma'am.
Hello, fellow bug.
Oh, bury my mother pale and slight.
Burry my father with his eyes shut tight.
Burry my sisters two by two.
And then we're done.
Let's bury me too.
Ha ha, do you know that one?
It's one of my favorites.
You can sing something else if you like.
in.
I bet you have a beautiful singing voice.
So, what are you doing down here for?
You came to Giga Wealthy.
Just look around you.
These mines are still bursting with riches.
There's plenty for everyone.
Just grab a pick and join in.
Ha ha.
Over the night where I broke a nail for the priest.
Something about a crown?
I can't remember the rest of that one.
Ha ha.
Maybe I'll just hum it.
Yearns for the mines.
This is what the mine does when you yearn for too long.
Okay, nice.
Alright, this way we go.
Any secrets?
No?
I guess I'll just stand here then.
Come on, farm.
Give me a...
Give me a natural disaster!
Give me a horrific accident right now!
now.
I demand my horrific mining accident.
I guess that's not gonna work.
Not yet.
God damn.
Can't get my final destination.
Be careful.
What do you wish for?
Okay.
Where do I go then?
I mean, I guess I could fight.
That seems like a boss right there.
Wait, is that silk stuff?
Is that song real?
Is she...
Is she Mary Silksong?
Right there on my far left?
Oh hey, it's this guy again.
Oh shit, he can hit up?
Oh shit, okay.
Now I know.
Okay, he's too big.
Oh wait.
Jane Silksong real?
Oh shit.
That's right.
Get cheesed.
Can't do nothing.
You're too big.
You're too wide.
Stupid.
Get cheesed.
Oh, that must be for an upgrade later.
All right, left we go.
Oh, he can't do his big jumps because it blocks.
Nice.
All right, off we go.
Oh, I should full heal.
All right, this should be a boss room, right?
Or Jane Silksong.
Miss Silksong, is this you?
Ooh, that's a closed gate.
Me up here.
Ma'am, did you hear that news?
You're getting a sequel.
After seven years.
Okay.
Oh.
Oh, that is not...
Guys, I don't think that's Silk Song.
I...
Unless she went on a very, very good diet.
I have a feeling that's not Ma'am's Silk Song.
I...
A horror ozempic.
I'm like, damn, ma'am.
Oh my god.
I'm bullying.
I'm a bullying child.
Are you done?
Are you done now?
Oh,
shit.
Okay.
I'm gonna...
Oh.
Okay, I thought that was the...
Alright.
You done with your little temper tantrum?
Sir?
Oh.
I mean, I can heal here.
Oh shit, I can't heal here!
I can't!
Oh shit!
I don't know when it's the...
The fire strike.
Oh wait, I could just do that.
Never mind, I shouldn't do that.
Okay, it's fine.
I'm safe here.
Don't worry about the five-strike shit.
Oh, there it is.
There's the five-strike.
This is very predictable.
I can get three hits in.
Oh, my God.
How did I dodge that?
Nice.
All right, cry.
Cry, little boy.
That's right.
Right!
Mama hates you!
That's why you're here by yourself.
Doing your mama's...
Oh, shit.
I'm sorry.
Oh, goodbye.
Give me a sec.
Let me...
Kill in front of you, too.
Goodbye.
Oh,
my God.
It was a baby.
What did I get?
The city crest.
Oh my god, wait.
Is that a baby?
Oh, hello.
Where are you getting?
Why are you running?
Get over here!
Alright, what's this?
Oh, it's the baby's college fun.
Let's go.
Did I just kill the child?
I mean, it won't be the first time.
That's right, you saw what I did to him going after you next.
Yoink, my college fun now.
Not the last.
Yeah.
They think I'm fighting a boss fight?
Dirt fight?
I am the boss fight.
Wait, what's up there?
You're fighting me.
Hide your kids, hide your wives.
What's there?
Hello?
Oh, hey, a bench.
Alright, God fucking draw my map that I paid for.
Oh, who is that creeping out of the darkness?
Oh, you're looking grim.
A strange empty face and a wicked looking weapon.
Something important has drawn you down into Halene's corpse.
I won't ask why.
Perhaps the reason you found me is because you need my help.
Say no more, friend.
I want to give you a gift.
A nasty little spell of my own creation.
It's just perfect for a little one like you.
Oh, what do I get?
Like, magic?
What is that?
See, when a strange lady tells you to take it...
Oh, consume the vengeful spirit.
the spirit spells what they please oh i got a spell nice i told you guys zero survival instincts and strange old lady in this random cavern told me to told me to um touch her glowing her glowing orb and i did it with zero hesitation oh you're looking at last i apologize perhaps i should have warned you about the power of that spell i was watching over you as you slept it seemed that i slipped away myself oh now we're awake i was wondering whether you'll do me a favor not as repayment for my gifts of course simply because we're now friends you see a horde great beast has made its home in the heart of this temple such disrespect I would be quite grateful you're to venture deeper in and slay it for me it's hardly it's a hardy creature but your new power you're more than match for it good luck with this small favor my friend all right wait oh shit Okay,
that shit is strong.
But then it's like, do I use it for spells?
Or do I use it to heal?
That to, like, manage that.
I have to manage my soul this correctly.
Alright, I'll back up.
Just gotta do a favor for my friend.
Ow.
Okay, let me heal it.
I think if it's, like, the small...
If I just lose one HP from the small one, I just heal instantly.
Since I can recharge those very easily.
The souls of the children.
Okay, I can't jump for this.
Alright.
Well, I can touch that odd.
Oh, shit!
Parkour, my natural enemy.
Alright.
Go this way.
Where the fuck is the...
The squatter.
I have to kill a squatter for the nice old lady.
No squatters allowed here.
Is it this guy?
Fuck you!
That's right!
Can't hide now!
I've got spells!
That's right.
Stop squatting!
Pay your rent!
Wait, was that him?
I don't even know if that was the squatter.
Not gonna lie.
Soul catcher.
Oh,
I got him, man.
Wait, there was more up top, so I'm going to check up there.
Okay, so there was another squatter.
Like, I don't even remember.
I wish I'd marked it on the map.
God damn, I should have bought the goddamn DLC tracker.
Okay.
Isn't there another area that I haven't gotten?
That's over there.
Oh, shit, nice.
I guess he doesn't want to live in the world anymore after I killed his dad.
Understandable.
Yeah, there's something here that I didn't go to.
What is it?
Oh, it was just a skull thing.
Anything else here?
Yeah.
I feel like killing these guys is just not worth it.
Just a waste of my time.
Oh, I get over.
Oh, wait, nice.
And I'm gonna steal your college buttons, too.
Oh, that's a cocoon!
I found this.
I found Silk Song, guys.
Oh, yeah, I should double check.
Wait, give me a sec.
Oh, my gosh.
I need to make sure...
I'm gonna double check that sound.
I wasn't looking when I asked my sound guy if everything was good.
I had to double check.
Alright, tap back in.
Alright, I killed the squatter.
What do I get?
Also, it's Sundan.
You slain the beast.
That poor thing.
It must have been terrified of you.
It used to be quite docile.
But a rancid air in these caverns filled it with some ancient rage.
Can't believe it!
He used to pay rent and didn't?
What a fool.
Here we go.
Thank you for the five gift of ships.
Thank you.
So, we did what you had to be done.
You have my gratitude, of course.
We both know you wouldn't have made it throughout that spell of mine.
Oh, oh, oh.
I'm sure you're eager to move on.
Farewell and have faith.
I am the evictor.
They hired me to help evict people.
Whatever you're seeking, they will find you.
Oh, oh, oh.
That's what they all say.
They used to be good.
and then he got into some bad juju
okay this has to be unlocked oh what sorry i'm sorry i missed you when you're feeling lost why not pop up to your store in derfmouth and purchase a map of this area available now at an excellent price yeah oh ben just get rid of the xp boost i had an xp boost I,
I was like, I did?
Who was the guy that docked my way last time?
I was like this way, right?
Oh, HP boost.
Okay.
Oh, it was this way, I remember now.
Alright, gotta kill another squatter.
Was it here?
Wait, actually, no, it wasn't.
It wasn't here.
It was...
Is it right?
Okay, who's the person living over here?
Oh, it's a hot spring.
Okay.
That's just a bench.
Alright, uh...
Where do I go?
I have new equipment.
Oh, I do.
What do I need to do?
What are my equips?
What is this?
Used by draw morsels.
Oh, nice.
I like that.
I get to have more...
I get to extort more money from people.
That's good.
I knew they were hiding more in the pockets.
I knew it.
Can't hide from me.
Gotta pay your debts.
I'm the loan shark.
I'm gonna break your fucking kneecaps.
Oh, oh, souls?
Oh, shit, okay.
The souls of the children.
I mean, that's good too, I guess.
Um, we haven't not gone yet.
Up and left?
Up and left.
Ow!
What the fuck?
Did you spit on me?
That's right.
The kids aren't seeing our mother time soon.
Up, up, up.
Oh!
Okay, I gotta get 20.
No, I haven't saved anybody's children yet.
Okay, this way.
Is it here?
Is that... Oh, the squatter's here.
Wait, I remember now.
I think the squatter's up here.
It was like...
yeah right
no fuck where is he squatting I need to evict someone I'm trying to fucking gather my next paycheck for the eviction it's like those dead collectors like spamming your phone number this is where he lives Oh my god, there you are.
Sir, you didn't pay your rent.
Oh my god, I don't have enough souls.
Oh shit, nice.
Nice.
I can kill your kid.
And absorb the soul of your child.
There you go.
Okay, I can't get there yet.
Alright, this way.
The green path.
What's the green path?
Hello?
Oh, they know.
I see my crimes have traveled to this world, too.
They're like, oh, no, she's here!
Oh, no!
It's Sean Holland that she made it to Greenpath!
She got past the defenses!
Get the...
Get the kids, honey, and run!
That's right, the landlord.
Oops.
The landlord is coming.
Don't mind that.
Don't mind the father.
Oh, shit.
Are these like poisonous to orange beams?
Okay, they are.
All right, that answers my question.
It's time to touch grass.
Okay, this way.
Yeah, that felt like a secret.
Oh, shit.
Wait, what?
Oh!
Okay, now I know.
Alright, if you wanted to kill me, you gotta do that a little faster, sir.
Music is nice here.
Yeah, it's pretty cute.
Alright.
Up, Paco.
I want to make sure there's no secret there.
I'll find a... Oh, I don't have a map for this.
God, I have to buy a map for each area?
Why can't I destroy myself?
I already have a pen.
God, fucking goddamn map DLC.
What's this?
Oh.
I ran out of paper.
I'll destroy it on the leaves.
I'm literally surrounded by leaves.
I don't need paper.
Are you a cartographer?
Oh my god!
Jane Silk's on!
Oh shit, goodbye.
She gotta go to her sequel now.
It got released, she heard.
For the map fun.
SX, thank you for the Majessa Supa.
Thank you.
I'm getting fucking... I'm getting extorted now by goddamn Cornelius.
Oh shit, I didn't die Yeah Silk Sook is real Or people need her How the fuck?
Do I have to go back to dirt map?
She's real, quick Take a picture
Okay How the fuck do I get to that?
Oh my god, I'm so lost I'm like Reflexively checking my map because I assume I can assume since I already have a pen that I could draw the map myself but no he apparently has the monopoly on all maps
I guess I don't have a license to draw new maps
I can't jump that cut the vines this okay
I don't even know what looks like vines here I ran out of paper.
Oi, you got a license for that?
Are you driving maps illegally, sir?
Let me just rest.
I'm angry.
Let me sit down and see if a little.
Illegal maps will not be tolerated in Green Town.
Oh, shit.
Fuck these, yeah, I'm- sorry, I was a little angry there.
Whoops.
Just remember not to draw maps under the influence.
I don't know where I am.
I don't know where I am anymore.
Oh, shit, I forgot.
Baby explodes.
Don't draw a drink, yeah.
Don't cartographer a drink, guys.
whoops that's why Christopher Columbus thought that whoops thought that he could get to like what was India by sailing across the ocean
oh this okay that's the vine you guys wanted me to cut oh what's the point What's the point of cutting that?
What does that do?
Yeah.
Menace, thank you for the...
Fuck you.
Let me heal real quick.
Oh my god, there he is.
I hear him.
I'm ready to buy my map DLC.
Okay.
Is that a cause of contrast or the crossroads?
Trash a human and lively place?
The road switch to turn in the most wonderful ways.
I thought my best to check the area ahead.
I must remove some of the area and have it as for quite a nuisance.
Oh my god, he upped his prices!
90% of the work.
Paper does not cost $60.
Where is a Walmart in Hollow Knight?
Why does he sound like that?
He is upcharging me $60 for a map.
This is why he sounds like that.
Do you want the map or not?
He has the paper in Monopoly.
God damn it.
inflation hit hard in Hollow Knight.
Okay, where am I?
Alright.
We're here.
Okay, so I can go down and right.
Down and right.
Okay, I have to go down.
I hate him.
I hate him so much.
I hate him in this stupid monopoly.
Eat the rich.
When can I eat him?
This is cheap!
Oh yeah, I can't believe terrorists hit all night.
I thought I was safe
I can't believe it ever since I crossed the border to Greenland Things got more expensive.
It's so fucked up I remember when paper was $30 guys.
I
map prices went up since silk song was announced the mask skyrocketed mask thank you for the super chat thank you thank you
he knew i needed it more than he knew this
this is getting too real too key this is supposed to be my comfort game What's that?
Is he a bad person?
Time to squib.
You approach squib fearless.
Are you a hunter like me?
Do you feel the urge inside of stock to kill to understand?
Then take it, my journal.
It will aid you.
At first, the text may seem difficult to discern.
But learn, hunter will come to understand its words.
Venture the depths of this land and slay its beast.
Prove yourself worthy to bear the mark of the hunter.
Oh, shit, nice.
Free stuff.
See, this is why you go...
This is why you go in with no fear or zero sense of...
Zero sense of survival instincts.
So you can get free stuff like this.
Yay!
Look at that.
If you don't venture into the nun, you won't get...
free stuff you don't need self-preservation when you get free things wait I hear him I hear the child I hear my next paycheck oh it's over there whoops I thought like wait where oh it was here yeah my $20 let's go
Okay, this way.
He has to pay off a four-year guitar.
He has got to pay his loans, guys.
The photography school was so expensive.
Please understand, Lolly.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Whoops.
Where did I go?
I mean, sure.
I guess I'll go here.
Chain silk sign.
Man, please.
You gotta go to your sequel.
You gotta hurry, it's releasing next week!
Oh, you're not a child.
Oh, no.
Okay, never mind.
Not that child.
What?
What are I...
Man, shoot me.
Okay.
Nice.
Not the right child.
Oh.
Oh, it's like Pong.
Yay!
Wait, how do I do this?
Oh, it's here.
Oh, yo, I'm so good at pawing.
This way?
What's over here?
Whoa, it's awfully dark in here.
Oh, shit.
All right, that's fine.
I have the souls of the children to absorb.
Nice.
Come on.
You're depressed.
Oh wait.
Come on.
Oh shit!
Okay.
Never mind.
I'm not playing with my food anymore.
Oh?
Door.
Hello?
Oh!
Alright.
Let's not do that.
Oh my god, there has to be an easier way.
Oh.
Okay.
Do I go?
Okay, this way.
Oh, this fucking level sucks, guys.
I can't see anything!
Where am I?
Yeah, there has to be an easier way.
I'm like, this can't be.
I was like, this can't be right.
Yeah, it's called a flashlight.
God damn it!
It's called a flashlight.
Yeah I'll come back later.
I'll mark it on my bench.
Oh, down.
Down I go.
Am I making good progress?
I can't tell.
I feel like, I definitely feel like, um, I definitely feel like I've been stuck for a while in some areas.
Oh shit.
And I fall!
Take more damage?
Okay, let me grab some HP.
Okay, that was bullshit.
The fact that falling actually, I got hit and I fell and that took two of my life.
It's not not considered...
Wait, where's the bench?
Oh, wait, there's a bench.
There was a bench over here.
Yeah.
Just go to the bench.
Wait, no.
It's above me.
God damn it, it was above me.
If I'm gonna, I'm gonna take your money.
Okay.
Okay, it's this way.
I need the ladder.
DLC.
Alright, there's the bench.
There we go.
And I updated my map too.
Okay, I have to go down and do like some freaky ass parkour shit.
In this way.
Oh, I don't care about these guys.
Alright.
I do some wiki ass parkour.
Okay, down I'll go.
Whoa, what's this?
There's like eggs down there.
Wait, jellyfish, can I kill them?
Oh, I can.
Oh, it's- I'm under water.
Ow!
Okay, now I know.
Now I know that hurts.
Oh my god, not the fucking water level.
They're the worst.
Water levels are always the worst levels.
Oh my god, get me out of here.
Get me the fuck out of here.
Jesus Christ.
Oh my god.
Simple geometry.
Eh.
I shouldn't channel my...
inner demons real quick.
The thing is, I don't know where I'm going.
I'm just going down.
Gambit, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
The queen station is this fast.
I'm in another area.
Where am I?
Oh my god, I don't have the DLC for this one either.
I gotta find fucking Cornelius again.
Isn't this something?
I did not expect to discover so huge a stack station after that fog.
descent.
The bugs of Holoness must have been an impressive lot.
Building such great structures so far into the wilds.
Seems the dangerous creatures about haven't yet made their way in here.
It's a perfect place for a quick rest.
Oh my god, and I bet you he's gonna charge me like $100 now.
This stupid who gave him the monopoly?
Why is he the only cartographer in this bug world?
Let me end!
I'll go to university for cartography!
And then I'll make sure I'll take all the And I'll steal all his customers.
I'll charge myself $1 less than his prices.
Fuck this man.
There's only like five bugs left alive, Doki.
I'm going to map him out of business.
I'll go back to school just to take his business away.
That's how petty I am.
Like, where do I go?
What the fuck?
Who's she?
Hello.
Oh my god.
She's so tall.
Tall women.
Oh, come in search of treats, have you?
I chanced upon a unique little fungus growing right above us.
I found it only in this station, and the taste is just fine.
Hello again.
Thank you, thank you.
You guys, you have the little nightmares, pro tag.
Oh, yeah!
I mean, the OmniMage 3 is coming out soon.
Alright, another share.
God, I wish I had a paper to draw this map in.
Smelly, thank you for the super chatting.
Thank you, Doki.
Please help.
I played slots on a cruise and kept winning, and now I think I'm a gambling addict.
Please tell me to stop gambling.
I've been leaving all my decisions to little coin flip in the past two weeks.
Oh, my God.
think I think that's when you know you gotta stop thank you with the super chat thank you thank you there's an inspect where I don't even know where I am guys I I
don't even know where quick is this a stack station oh at that bench oh where what oh this was the bench oh
there it is oh I didn't see whole machine with a simple, oh, whatever, just take my money.
Everybody's doing it anyway.
To be fair, I like how I'm like ring, ring, ring.
Oh, hey, there he is.
Oh my god.
Where's the stag?
I like how it's like, it's my money even though I also took other people's money for this.
Greetings, little one.
It's been an age since I've last heard the ring of a station bell.
It echoed down the stagways and called me to him.
I've grown stiff and tired over these many years And I forgot much The sound of the bell Will always call me back Yeah, I'm the sole customer in Hollow Nest Also doesn't help that I've killed many people So there's been a lack of customers These stagways stretch the dust of Hollow Nest They want to travel them Tell me from the platform I will take you where you need to go Wait,
I need to go to Dirtmouth To get my upgrades Oh
Where is this area?
Gotta buy my goddamn map DLCs.
Oh, it's the graveyard.
Just keyed it.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Uh, yeah, last save and return to title.
It responds to you that pension keeps everything.
I ain't no quitter.
I ain't no coward.
I'm not gonna save scum.
Alright.
I'm going to buy this pin because I feel like I might need it.
And then...
I don't think I need any of these, though.
Talk to the old man, alright?
A little old man.
My dragoons want me to talk to you.
Oh, what a turn.
Our sharp thieves come home.
Just wandered back in.
I hope for grand tales of his time below.
But seems to remember nothing.
Maybe it was all too much for him.
If you're interested in what his wears, watch out.
He drives a hard bargain.
No competition.
That's the problem.
Oh, you're judging this man when the cartographer has been charging me DLC for every place I go?
It's bad for the market.
Not that he's complaining.
Why are you judging him?
We should be judging this couple.
This couple is a menace to society.
Everyone's got a monopoly.
Potomac, chill.
All right.
piece of soul vessel, you know, these ghastly looking orbs.
Wait, what's this?
Do you find us a leaving Wagyu behind as Jill?
Oh!
Wait, I like that.
Yeah, not... This charm grants you more time to recover.
Wait, I'm gonna...
Oh, there's the...
Oh, there's the lantern!
I'll get this one.
Oh my god, there's the lantern DLC.
Yeah, why don't you draw the map here?
I'm trying to!
That's what I've been trying to draw!
But then somehow I ran out of paper, and he has a monopoly on paper, too.
Okay.
I don't think I can equip it yet, though.
Yeah, I can only...
Alright.
Hello, I'd like to travel, please.
Just steal here.
his favorite.
Alright.
What's the purple pin?
I don't even remember.
Oh, it's fine.
We'll get it.
I can't even equip it anyway.
Don't blame the market.
Blame it.
I like to have souls, though.
Actually, what would be?
I'll go with souls for now.
I won't get out of here.
Unless I can find, like, the next cartographer for this area.
Where did I come from.
Here?
Yeah, because I can't dash anywhere.
Oh my god.
And I need a fucking map for this area, too.
Hello.
Hello there, dearie.
I was about to close up shop and run till you came along.
I provide a banking service if you're interested.
Losing one to you is a terrible thing and it's so much more likely if you carry it all by yourself.
My fault is much more secure in all my time as a banker i've never wait i could lose my geo i've never died yet so i didn't know maybe consider opening account wait i have oh my god there better be interest rates there better be okay i didn't know i never died yet geo
best of you you'll but god to know your chios safe within my or my vault now let's do some banking all right i guess i'll i'll put my 19 in there wait where's my money why can't i deposit like
hello don't tell me it has to go by a hundred you won't take my 19 oh i starts 50 okay
I'm too poor.
I opened an account and now I don't have the money to even use my account.
No small bills, apparently.
It's fucked.
Oh my god, get out.
Get me out of here.
Are you serious?
That hits me?
Oh my god, get me out of this area.
okay nice i don't know where he went but nice god i hate this area so much i'd rather just fight the bugs
okay i can't do anything here
all right i don't even have the 50 to invest are you serious oh i thought that I legitimately thought that that wouldn't get that hits me too no my first death my buddy I wasn't paying attention oh I can't it's the water of course it's the fucking water level that kills me a fucking course okay now I know I can actually lose my money okay now I know wait is this like the souls like where like the money I can get my money back if I find it.
Thank God.
Thank God I went to the bank.
And deposit zero dollars, guys.
Thank fucking God.
Okay, so I can.
Oh, so it is like a source like there.
Okay.
That's cool.
God, I hate this area.
Oh, my.
Oh, it does two damage.
damage okay okay that makes sense I was like how the fuck did I die so fast I thought I had more HP but it does too okay it does two hits that makes sense yeah I don't even know where I died oh my Oh my gosh, it was like $20 anyway.
Oh, there I am.
Okay, nice.
Got my $20 back.
Oh, $30 too.
Nice.
Okay.
I'm just trying to figure out where the fuck to go, to be fair.
Oh my god!
Jesus, it's like a homing missile.
Oh, the explosion does too?
Oh.
Okay.
Ah, shit.
I got greedy.
I got really greedy there.
Are you serious?
Are you?
What?
Okay!
Get me out of here.
I hate this place.
I actually hate this place so much.
I don't want to do this area anymore.
Okay.
This place fucking sucks.
Oh my god.
Get me back into the greens.
Fuck this.
I want to go back to the green area.
Get me out of here.
I hate this place.
Okay, my back into my safety area.
I'm gonna die here, aren't I?
Alright.
I'm gonna go this way.
Why is the bank so far?
Does she not have a franchise?
The fact that the bank is so far, too.
Like, I have to go through the ocean to fucking get to that bank.
Like, fuck that shit.
Okay.
No, we don't need the bench.
I'm going forward.
It's okay.
We don't need it.
Okay, miss last words.
But we don't need it.
I'm stronger than that.
I'm a strong independent John Hollow Knight.
I'm privately owned big.
That's most bigs.
Oh, shit.
Okay.
Sorry, my depth perception failed me.
Get out of here.
Get your ass out of here, child.
Okay, maybe I should get him closer.
But...
That's fine.
I need your money anyway.
Affair, I'm thinking about five gifted chips.
Thank you, thank you.
Okay.
Nice.
I need the souls of the children just to save me.
Wait, why?
Why is he there?
Is there a secret?
Oh.
We assume there'll be a secret there.
Alright.
Oh.
Child?
He's like, I don't want to play no more.
Playtime isn't over, you guys.
over here you started this fight oh shit there yeah okay Jane silk song is over there but I want to go up here
and maybe there'd be something interesting over here oh shit oh my god it lasts so long oh my god That's it.
I'm following J.L.
Silkson.
I'll follow her.
I don't want to deal with that.
Oh, wait.
There's something down here.
Oh, I can't make it.
Never mind.
That's why I'm going to delay Silkson for another two years.
Then she went up.
Okay.
Why did she go up here?
you.
Alright.
Yummy, yummy.
Yummy souls.
Oh, shit.
I didn't see that guy.
Oh, my god.
Stupid fucking platforms.
You're safe now.
But I'm gonna get you.
See, I told you I was gonna get you.
I didn't lie about that.
I jump from here?
I can't.
Okay.
Inspect.
Oh my god.
Fine.
Give me fast travel.
That's fine.
Oh, wait.
Oh, it was a toll.
I'm literally, this town's only...
I feel like I'm the town's only customer.
Like, did no one else open that toll?
Like, how am I the only one that's opened it?
Like...
Oh, I wanted to see if that was like a platform.
No, it was just a building.
Oh, shit.
I was trying to do the...
I was trying to do the little pogo jump.
I'm so bad at this pogo jump shit.
It's like, why pogo jump on them when they're right in front of me?
You know?
Oh my god.
Yeah, I know that I've seen I've seen people Pogo a lot In this game So I know like it's an actual requirement But I'm just so bad at it I'm not used to Pogo jumping in this game Where's this here I hear a child Where is this child But I can't even get there Okay I don't have a dash.
You literally just started playing, Doki.
You're not gonna know yet.
The greater of mine once dreamed of leaf and castes caverns so, in every bush and every vine, the mine unreveals itself to us.
What does that mean?
Don't understand, guys.
I'm a gamer!
I should know how to poke a right away!
The moment I was boy, I should know how to do a 360 noscope.
Well, is he a bad guy?
Oh, he is a bad guy.
Boom!
Oh, this time.
Oh, this is when I need a pogo, right?
Oh, shit.
Oops.
Oh, my God.
He has better reflex than me, apparently.
Well, never mind.
He's dead.
I guess not.
I spoke too soon.
He's dead.
Alright.
I hear a child, but...
I don't know if there's, like, a secret around me.
I hear him.
I hear him crying.
I hear my $20 paycheck.
I swear...
Okay, I was gonna say, if...
If I'm, like, in a new area...
And he's like, you don't have a paper for that.
Where am I, though?
Now I wish I had a bench nearby.
Oh.
Oh, I got you.
I think he mad.
I stole his meal.
That's my soul!
Excuse me, sir.
That's my meal.
Oh, shit.
Whoops.
Wrong way.
Oh, my God.
Okay, I wasted all that.
I thought... I don't know.
I thought the projectile would be bigger.
Get down from here!
Oh, this is a horde.
He's a coward.
Okay.
Nice.
Money, money, money.
Must be funny.
And a rich man's word.
Alright, hello.
Just what do you think you're doing, man?
You dare to come between me and my prey?
Is it a... Get on my hand.
Is it having yours to screw you about, man?
Getting away and causing bother?
Know this, girl.
I am Zot, the mighty.
A knight of great renown.
cross me again man you'll find out why they call me weapon life ender i literally saved your fucking life why are you still bothering me for man on my night i'm not interested in your childish games i need my rest be gone all right goodbye sir i can hope that that guy eats you next time all right where am i god damn it i still need a find a goddamn chair.
Don't be rude as Zoka mighty.
He is mighty.
Did you not see his name?
I will kill this child.
Come on!
Come out!
You started this!
That's lucky, right?
Respect your elders, Toki.
He has to earn my respect.
Oh, fuck this.
This guy is actually so annoying.
Green children, watch from the dreams onto this lands.
Here we shall now shall wait patient for the call to return.
The secret is just lore?
Alright, this way.
Oh shit, it's him.
I keep forgetting that...
Oh my god, I keep forgetting about this guy.
Oh my god!
Okay, wait.
Wait, wait a minute, wait a minute.
Wait a minute.
Oh my god, and he can do projectiles too?
Wait, this guy is harder.
Wait, he's a lot harder than...
He is a lot harder than the other guy.
What the fuck?
He does double hit now?
Okay.
Alright, at least I can save my...
Nice.
This guy was a lot harder than the first one.
Because he like double hit and everything.
Yeah.
This way.
Oh, less base?
Oh, maybe.
It felt a lot harder.
Come no closer, ghost.
I've seen you creeping through the undergrowth, stalking me.
This old kingdom, a terrible thing awakens.
I can smell it in the air.
I know what you are.
I know what you try to do.
I can't allow it.
What did I do?
Wait, this is a boss fight?
Oh, shit!
Okay, this might be where I die.
I was not prepared for a boss fight.
Oh!
Oh, shit.
Hello.
I ain't grabbing.
Adidas?
Okay, I can do a heal here.
No, I can't!
That's I could.
I should say Adidas, isn't it?
What the fuck?
Oh, unlucky.
I need an extra heal.
Oh, wait.
Oh, that was like a free hit.
all right i gotta focus a little bit oh get as many hits as possible nice
oh this music is kick ass though i like the music for this please ma'am you gotta get make it in time for silk son i can't kill you or we're gonna delay silk Son!
Adidas.
There you go.
Nice.
Wait, that's easy.
They made a sequel for you?
The Moth... Oh my god, I can finally dash.
Use the cloak to dash quickly along the ground.
No wonder it took seven years.
That's it.
We did it.
We killed Silksai.
Use the cloak to dash quickly along the ground or through the air.
Oh, nice.
Fucking finally.
That's actually what we needed.
What?
Would it seek to break the seals?
They cannot be a done.
They must be undone.
Let us keep sleep, little shadow.
Turn to your darkness.
Allow us our peace.
We did it.
We cancelled Sip-Song, guys.
Because she's needed seven years to train for Sip-Song.
Okay.
We're at the break the seal?
Whatever that is.
Oh, thank God.
Whoops.
Wait, why can't I grab that?
Excuse me, sir.
Oh, wait.
Oh, I have to...
I have to dash from...
there, I see.
Oh, shit!
Whoops.
That was an oopsie.
But there was something over there.
I want to check over here.
We'll make sure I'm not missing anything.
Oh, this is where I came from, right?
Yeah, this is where I came from.
Whoops.
I might have panicked a little.
You might be able to beat this before Silk Song at this rank.
Alright, well, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Wait, was that boss fight supposed to be hard?
I mean, her moves are pretty predictable.
I might be bad at platformers, but...
I have reflexes at least, I guess.
Oh my god.
my first bench.
Oh, I still can't afford it.
When can I upgrade?
Oh, she's a noob filter?
Ha ha!
I ain't no noob!
Go on.
Oh, hello there.
Seems we both tread far from the path.
I can hardly believe those dusty old highways led to such a lush and lively place.
This building suggests some form of worship.
Not a noob!
Let's go!
That's right.
You're watching a gamer!
Though, its idol has clearly been long forgotten.
Doubles equally well for a moment's respite.
Not last.
Nice.
Stupid.
That's right.
Maybe if you did...
Bullshit!
Give me a second.
Okay, I should leave.
Okay.
I gotta jump for your money.
Alright, let's head home, I guess.
Oh, shit.
God damn it.
I feel like I'd lose more HP from just the platforms and not the enemies.
The enemies are not the thing I have to worry about.
Han, thank you for the five gifted ships.
Thank you, thank you.
Alright, where do I go now?
Now that I got the dash, I guess I go this way.
Okay.
Is there anything over here first before I go?
I hear...
I don't know if they're the kids?
If they're my $20 paychecks or...
Or what?
Where am I?
Oh, there's a bench.
Nice.
Okay, gotta draw my little map.
I can't...
Why can't someone else pay for these tollers?
Why does it have to be me?
God damn it.
Get over here.
There is no... Because you keep killing everyone else, Doki!
No one else is traveling.
Why is it always me?
I'm literally this world's only customer.
I'm keeping everybody afloat right now.
I'm their only customer.
Where do I go here?
Was that the boss?
Let's see.
Here is an area to my far, right?
I'll go to the right side.
This entire economy, the capital's GDP is powered by one single bug.
That's so sad.
This way.
Have I killed you before?
Or are you new?
Alright.
I don't know they respond.
So I don't know.
What the fuck?
Oh, he respawned?
Okay, but you do have a lot of money.
So I'm going to rob you.
Nikita, thank you for the super chat, thank you, thank you.
Hello, I'm the resident green path.
I was on my way to the tofu, but some of this beady-eyed bug in a hoodie just ran up and stabbed me and stole my wallet.
Now I'm stuck and unable to go off.
Who could do such a thing?
Did you report to the police, sir?
Oh, my God.
Who could do such a heinous crime?
Someone's got a, we gotta have a neighborhood.
watch guys don't worry I volunteer don't worry citizens I shall volunteer myself to be the neighborhood watch I do require a salary though what oh my god I don't have a map for this area too How many areas is he gonna charge me?
Like, where does this end?
Oh,
nice.
My $1.
That's... Oh, whoa.
It's a cave.
Oh, cool.
Oh, not cool anymore.
Wait.
This is not cool.
Wait, not cool.
Oh, wait.
If I stay here, I can just... Wait a minute.
I didn't think things through.
Like, I could...
Oh, shit.
This guy is so annoying, though.
There we go.
What the fuck?
Oh!
No!
Where am I?
Oh!
The Rick Ricochet!
Oh my god, I gotta look at the map again.
I lost to our ball.
The fucking ricochet got me.
Gotta remember where I died too.
That's fine, I don't need this.
Okay, I think I remember how to get there.
It's like here.
And then... here?
okay what do i it's like here here all right oh my god i'm getting impatient now
but when it first tried but died to a roly boy you don't understand you don't understand that roly boy he had a gun.
Guys, he had...
I swear to God, he had a gun.
Oh my god, I keep fucking that jump up, because I'm getting impatient.
Okay.
We do this again.
Oh, they're dead.
Oh!
I did it.
Never mind.
Oh, that sucks.
I didn't get to Keep the money, though, for a bit.
Oh, there's stuff to the right?
Okay, I'll check.
Oh, my God.
They're all roly boys.
The boulder shell.
What's that?
The hard shell.
Well, the shell is not...
Oh!
Oh, so when I heal myself, I can just use it.
I'm going to try to defeat the reins before the endless street...
the stream.
Wish me luck.
Sack.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
I have no idea what that is, but I bet you can do it.
You got this, bro.
Okay, am I back in the green lands?
Oh, I'm back here.
Am I supposed to go anywhere here?
Did I finish the green path yet?
I can't tell.
Alright.
We go this way then.
Now I got everything here.
Did I do it?
Did I beat the game?
Sam, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Okay, where else have I not gone?
Okay.
I've not gone down.
Okay, we'll do down.
Also, this map is fucking garbage.
Because there's like...
Because sometimes it says you have to go...
there's an exit that way but then like it's not the same as the area i'm in to access the exit oh get me out of here oh you know you don't you know you no i want your money you don't it i want your money there you go i'm having a bad day sir
i can zoom in i can't can't?
Wait, unless I have to look here.
Oh, I oh, I can't.
Oh, wait, no, I can't.
Alright.
Let's see.
This is an oh, shit.
Okay, there is somewhere I haven't gone here.
Yeah, I haven't gone here yet.
Whatever this place is.
Oh, it's...
Oh, no, it's just this guy.
Every time I remotely hear like, I think it's my paycheck, but it's not.
Okay.
It's these little guys.
They sound just like the little worms.
Okay, this way.
Alright.
Get out of here.
You don't even drop that much money.
You're not worth my time.
time where
am i oh i'm here okay okay i don't need a b here oh my god how do i get out of this okay i go back
yeah thank you for the super chat thank you thank you resident forgotten crossroads here i was recently orphaned after some maniac came over and shot my mom with the fireballs someone's gotta get this guy i know right whoever this man is he is a danger to our society to our to our neighborhood but don't worry your neighborhood watch got you guys we will apprehend this we will apprehend this menace to society now we're so hard day and night to make sure you are all safe with
an additional 10.99 payment i will work over time for you dragons
I wasn't killing anybody those those bugs I killed deserved it they were vandals they worked for that person who's terrorizing our neighborhood
okay let's see I don't know did I finish this area?
can't tell I guess I gotta go down.
It was self-defense, guys.
They were gonna rob me.
I was just defending myself.
I'm literally just taking it all because I just don't care.
Alright, this way.
Downstairs.
Overtime payment.
Thank you for this.
Thank you for this super chat.
Thank you.
Don't worry.
I will catch I will catch whoever has been vandalizing our safe and wonderful neighborhood.
If it's the last thing I do.
Oh shit.
Whoops.
That was a that was the wrong button.
What's this?
Oh, I have to go here.
Won't somebody think of that chill?
Oh my god, it's these types.
Oh my!
Okay, wait, wait, wait.
It's not that important.
It's...
Okay, wait.
Okay, if I can get one more...
You got this, too.
Okay, we'll try this again.
We'll try this again.
Let's try it.
Let me get past the first part, though.
Okay.
Okay, there we go.
We did it.
Scorns of agony.
Oh my god.
This shit better be fucking important.
All right, where do I go now?
I keep actually pressing the wrong button.
I guess I'll go down?
Seems to be something downstairs.
All right, to the far left.
Oh.
Where am I?
Oh, I had to go up.
I was like, what the fuck?
Where did I go?
Okay, this way.
Alright, let me look at the map while we're going.
Let me get my GPS going first.
Okay, I haven't gone this way yet.
Oh, man.
Okay.
It's like all Pogo's.
Wait, where do I go from here?
Wait, what?
There's like nothing there.
How the fuck am I supposed to head there?
Yeah.
Oh, I can't do this yet.
I was going to sit.
What the fuck?
Alright, I finished this area.
Where do I go now?
Park Canyon?
I'm going to try and find a bench.
Oh, it's above me.
I'm going to get to the bench.
But let me grab this money first.
Oh my god, I need a toll here.
Oh my god.
Thank you for the 50 gift of chips.
Thank you, thank you.
Thank you so much for the support.
Don't worry.
I'll make sure I'll definitely keep the neighborhood safe now.
We will capture this menace.
So our children won't have to worry no more.
But thank you again.
I really appreciate it.
But 50 gift of chips.
I'll work night and day.
Crime rate did spike up since I started working.
But it's because whoever it is is getting scared.
So they're working extra hard and robbing everyone.
Okay, we got this area.
Now where do we go?
We go to fog canyon?
Where the fuck do I go?
Huh.
I go to Forgotten Crossroads?
Ow.
Yeah, they're getting desperate.
They'll slip up soon, guys.
Don't worry.
I'll protect you all.
Kind of fucking...
At least, I'm trying to read the map.
Oh, shit!
I was trying to read.
my map.
It's distracting me.
Here we go.
I guess we could go right.
Yeah, I'll go right.
What's over here?
Money!
Many.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
I know Doki is the neighborhood meant, but I just can't prove it.
How could it be me?
Yes, the crime somehow happens after I inspect the neighborhood, but it because they knew I was leaving, so they robbed the place after I left.
It could never, it couldn't be me.
I'm working so hard to protect all of us.
How could you say such a thing?
There is no.
Cossation does not equal correlation.
Or correlation does not equal causation.
Lying, thank you for the 10 gifted.
Thank you, thank you.
Thank you.
Sit down.
I forgot where to go.
I'm so lost.
Me here.
Ow!
Oh, I didn't go here.
Yeah, now I have dash.
Okay, this is new.
Hello.
Are you a bad person?
He seems nice.
Yeah, he seems like a nice guy, right?
It's like you go up to a bear.
Hello, are you friendly, Mr. Bear?
Are you a friendly bear or a bad bear?
Okay, I need to figure out a deal.
Okay, I just dash, I think, if he does that.
Okay, I'm getting hit by everything right now.
Okay.
It's like, is that my new pet?
Can you figure out how to fucking fight this guy?
He's very annoying.
I'll just do Pogo for this.
Yeah, Pogo for that.
Yeah, I'll dash for this.
Nice!
Oh my god, they're all kids.
Oh my god, it's three children in one.
It's like the Vincent adult man.
It's like three- It's three kids in a trench coat!
World class, thank you for these!
Five gift of chips, thank you, thank you.
It's three kids in a trench coat.
It is!
Three kids in a moss coat.
Alright.
Must be something here because they're making me parkour.
Oh.
Okay, I'll kill this guy.
Oh yeah.
It's a fucking coward.
Nice.
Alright.
Abaco.
I don't know, these are the toxic plants I feel like isn't really worth dealing with.
away all right what's over here anything on the right side actually ow fuck no oh not the double whammy oh it's money okay i knew it i have a feeling it was something because it was this was another pathway then there should be like something extra there the double tap
It's below me.
Oh, okay.
I was like, who's making these sounds?
Right in this way.
Oh.
Oh, I thought it would be another little cave, like last time.
Oh, $20 time.
No!
Okay, I got impatient with that.
I thought I was being real clever.
super impatient.
I misstimed it.
I got super impatient again.
My greed.
My greed is my hubris.
Yay, $20!
And how do I get over here?
What?
Can I not go over there yet?
There are greed sickens of you.
Alright.
Not yet.
Guess I leave then.
I'm not gonna do anything here.
I did everything I can.
Alright.
Back, I'll go.
Now what?
I guess I go back now?
There's so much... I didn't invite...
My only issue right now.
There's so much backtracking.
because i'm lost all the time i i'm making it worse for myself and that's why there's so much backtracking i i'm just perpetually always lost even when i have a map on me
all right i'm gonna go to that bench wait do i have to go to that bench i'm more supposed oh fog canyon
no no god damn it okay i just remembered like this area
all right okay time to go back to far canyon where i don't have a fucking goddamn map oh my god this better be cornelius
This better be the goddamn nerd.
What?
No!
I was like, why can't I go?
Let me in.
I was like, let me in.
Why wouldn't it let me in?
I was so confused.
I was like, maybe if I bash my head more, I think he will let me in.
Oh, okay.
I did that because I thought...
I thought it'll hit the other jellyfish, guys.
I legitimately thought, like, oh, that'll hit the other jellyfish, right?
Oh, my God.
Okay, I think it was this way.
Okay, I'm going to go to the bank real fast.
I'm not gonna...
I'm not...
Okay.
What?
Oh!
I was like, no!
Okay.
Okay, wait.
I don't want to go to the bank anymore.
Oh my god, the bank is downstairs.
I forgot.
Okay, one HP.
Oh my god, where is the bank?
Is this the bank?
No, this is not the bank.
Okay, but I can't get another HP, which is five.
Okay.
being like a lot more careful because i really hate this area i really really hate this area
all right i gotta heal here god damn it okay bank bank that's the bank all right take my money
all right a deposit all right nice When I buy stuff, do I have to withdraw money from her to buy things or like, um...
Or, uh...
Is it safe there forever?
Yes?
God damn it.
Why can't I have a credit card?
What the fuck?
Where is my bank credit card?
Eh.
These guys are annoying.
Because I can't do anything about it.
They're just...
They're just spinning at me.
It's fine.
We don't need a...
We don't need a bench.
We're unstoppable.
Maybe miss last words.
It's okay.
We don't need it.
We're unstoppable.
Okay.
I'll heal here.
We still don't need it.
Okay.
Nice.
The only way to really kill these guys is the Pogo.
They kill them efficiently.
Oh my god!
That explodes!
Emiko, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Like this game, you might really like Nine Souls.
It's a bit darker, but a lot of fun.
Also, bigger focus on parrying than dodging.
I've heard about it.
I've seen...
Oh my god, what the fuck?
Are these like...
Okay, yeah, never mind.
I'm leaving.
So, um, where is this bench?
Hey, guys.
Um, so, where is this bench that you speak of?
Oh, my God.
There he is.
And I don't have money.
I put it on a bank.
I try to invest in my future.
Why can't I do a higher jump?
This is annoying, actually.
Oh, Pogo?
Oh!
Okay, now I know.
Oh my god, wait.
That means there's money here.
Okay.
Okay, nice.
Oh my god, knowing him, he's gonna charge me $20, is he?
Actually, I have to find money here.
Okay.
Oh, shit!
It's okay.
Oh, my God.
We got cordyceps.
It's last of us.
Where are those monsters called again?
I forgot.
Let's see, infected guys.
The clickers.
Oh, my God, yeah.
Okay, obviously we can't do anything in this area.
area but we know okay wait but I have a marker oh I don't have a map for this
never mind I forgot I don't have a map for this area anyway I was like oh my god guys I got a marker that I can use to mark the map person I say as I don't even have the the map to do all of that yeah I need to go back to the bank Fuck this.
I was so proud.
I don't even know what she's doing here.
Bench is on my left.
Where's my bench?
Oh, shit.
Here?
Oh, the station.
The station bench, yeah.
Almost forgot about it.
Get over here.
Wait, actually, no.
I need to go back to the bank first.
I need to go back to the bench so I can...
I need to go back to the bank so I can grab my money back and then buy stuff.
And participate in capitalism.
Give me a sec, guys.
I gotta participate in capitalism real quick.
They rely on me the economy.
I'm literally holding this entire world's economy in place.
Their GPD is like one dokey.
As long as there's no withdrawal fee, we'll be fine.
Okay, we can buy the map from now.
Yeah, the D and GDP stats for dokey.
The gross dokey product.
Okay.
Alright.
I think I'm normal.
Ah, it's your friend who's got me at a perfect time.
I just about finished trying these nauseous caverns.
Very territorial types to make their homes in the area.
I suggest avoiding them where possible.
Right or below some strange feeling creatures give me quite a scare.
They seem quite an intelligent bunch.
In my youth, I'd upgrade the caves.
But I feel my maturity.
be able to outrun me or later turn violent.
And $75.
It's increasing.
The inflation is getting worse.
Okay, where am I?
All right, we can go down right.
I don't think we could go right, so...
You made him a creep!
Because he is one.
My current suspect is Cornelius.
Guys, good news.
I have a suspect for the neighborhood menace.
He is.
He is one of the suspects.
What the fuck?
The Hall of Seal.
I would have expected something else.
Ow!
I was trying to look at my map guys.
What does she see in him?
Thank you
for the super chat internet.
Thank you, thank you.
Oh my god, there's explosions everywhere and I'm scared.
okay let's grab the money here a man full of passion he is a loyal loving husband dokey you wouldn't understand I don't you're right I don't cuz he can't make me buy TLC I'm literally funding their wedding right now I'm funding their honeymoon wow yeah i'm gonna say sounds like waluigi wow when okay i need to talk this is like a pogo practice but anyway thank you for the super chat thank you thank you bagged a batty
Yeah, I am up here now.
That's a lot of mushrooms.
He looks like Uttama.
Oh, shit.
No, he looks like the mushroom character.
The Japanese mushroom character.
Oh, oh, shit.
Okay, this is.
a bit difficult oh my god i think i might actually die oh fuck okay all right i gotta be more careful when there were two of them no i remember oh my god it's so far i remember the spell but i was like do i use the spell or do i heal okay maybe i should have found a bench oh that is so far
all right it was oh we got all the money i forgot about all the money oh shit okay we gotta maybe my maybe he'll find me first before i find him is it mark like where i died oh it is okay it's fine it's not that far it is mark
okay I gotta get rid of these guys first.
Don't worry.
Maybe my soul will find me before I find him.
So he can't speak for her.
He haven't backed any maidens out.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Okay, it was like this way.
This way?
Which way?
Oh, this way.
I remember.
Come to me!
Okay, now I'll...
Okay, now I'll kill him.
Okay, I'll use it here.
Okay.
Alright, now I...
Okay, I need like...
I should just not save my...
like be uh less worried about saving uh spells because i need to remember that i can farm it super fast yeah okay now that i know that i can farm these super fast i can be more aggressive yeah that's good to know where does this go what does this sign mean i can't read
I just need to know
The city Ow
Oh civilization is that way Okay I was just like what Are they like a city full of good Oh Okay that did not look like a fucking wall Okay Sorry Sorry
No!
This area.
I'm going to the city.
The city seems very safe.
I'm good.
Wow.
No!
I'm fucking okay!
The city was not safe.
I think I got robbed.
And I got shanked in London.
I got wah Luigi.
Wah!
Damn, so cute.
Oh my god.
Okay, let's get out of here.
I'm just getting in front of me.
Okay, I'm losing it.
I'm losing it right now.
I need the HP.
I'm trying to remember how to get there.
Are you serious?
How am I- I'm just getting worse.
Oh wait, fuck this guy though in particular.
Oh my god, I forgot this explodes.
I'm just getting hit by everything.
What's this?
You can tell that I just stopped hearing.
I'm just letting the world take me.
Yeah, I remember how to get there.
Alright, I'm locking the fuck in now.
At least these guys don't...
Oh shit, whoops.
Yeah?
Okay, I assume they did not...
Okay, they respond.
At least...
Okay, I know they respond now.
You were about to say...
I was like, oh shit, that is.
At least they don't respond.
Where's my fucking ghost?
Wah!
There we go.
You won't get me now, Waluigi.
Wah!
Wow!
Okay, where am I?
Okay, downstairs is civilization.
It's crazy that I somehow managed to dodge every fucking bench possible.
What's over here?
Wow!
Hello?
Oh, hey!
Uh-huh.
creature.
You got the look of an adventurer.
So we much in common.
Searching for dangerous places, I?
Well, you're on the right track.
A long-necked critter warned me of a tribe deeper down.
Warriors, sorts, so she says.
And I'm itching for some serious combat.
Oh, shit.
I'm probably gonna have to fight them.
What?
Are they friendly?
Maybe they're friendly warriors, you know?
This way I'll go.
Yeah.
Oh!
Fuck.
One time that my thing didn't hit down.
That looked such like a secret, but it wasn't.
Jesus Christ.
Where do I go?
No!
Okay, nice.
Ewa, thank you for the raid.
Thank you.
I hope you have a good stream.
Okay, so I got a shortcut here.
Okay, so this is just a shortcut.
That's okay.
I don't want to go through that again.
This is a terrible shortcut.
I already go through this area.
Okay, I'm going to look down now.
Because I don't trust myself anymore.
Gamers do look down, chat.
It's a miracle.
This game has instilled so much PTSD in me that I've started looking down.
Oh my god, Jane Silk-Song!
I can't believe it.
Doki has finally started looking down.
Yeah, I need that, please.
I will go this way.
I know she went that way, but I'm gonna go this way.
I should know.
I should go this way.
away.
After money.
After money, I'll go to her now.
I thought you killed Silk Song.
I've only delayed it for another year.
But if I kill her again, I can delay it for two years.
Okay.
Is this a city?
Here ends the pilgrim's way.
Paul Ness' hearts lays open before you.
Proceed onward to share in its glory.
Okay, yeah.
Toki, what were we- I- I don't know.
I- I was like, maybe- maybe someone will pick me up.
You know?
Alright.
Well, I guess I'll go this way.
I haven't been here yet.
I hate these guys so much.
Oh!
Oh no.
Alright.
I'll grab his money.
And then we'll go this way.
Oh, wait, no.
This way is...
Wait.
I have never been here, though.
So where does this way lead me to?
Oh, fuck.
Okay, that's on me.
Oh, shit.
That's on me, too.
Oh, my God.
It's just vibrating.
Where am I?
Sure cut a head?
It sucks because I have...
Okay, how...
Okay, wait, I got it.
There you go.
I had a feeling that that's what I had to do.
Nice, $20.
Yay!
Alright, where does this lead me?
More money.
That's always a good thing.
Money?
No, paycheque.
You and I are different.
Alright, we got the shortcut.
So that means we can go here now.
Okay, so I clearly can't wall ride yet.
Hello.
Oh, shit, not friend!
I was like, hello, friend.
sir will you possibly be a friend of mine i forgot to charge my phone give me a sec also i actually sort of need to use the bathroom i'm not beat in three hours give me a sec i go use bathroom i'll be right back
okay i'm back we're gonna find a bench guys and then we're call it the moment i find a fucking bench i swear to god i have not i i've actually dodged every fucking bench in this game like i swear to god the last bench i found felt like 20 years ago where are the benches
i i do have a bench pin Where is it?
This certainly does feel...
I feel like I've dodged every bench in existence.
Oh my god.
While you're seeking death, welcome.
May you find Swift N upon our cloud.
I even bought the bench DLC!
I fucking hate him.
I hate Cornelius.
I hate him so much.
I did I did buy it He fucking Scared me
Oh my god Where is the closest bench guys Please Where is the closest bench?
Oh my god There it is God, please!
Okay, okay, it's this way.
Oh my god, there's the side.
There it is.
I see it.
We finally found our first bench.
Oh, there it is.
Alright, let's check the... Okay, I can upgrade one more.
Okay, I can put one more charm.
Lash is up.
One tates about tiny.
The shell is not indestructible.
Okay, we need this.
Alright.
So, no benches loud.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
That was was so fun though okay i've actually i've been enjoying holo night so far i like how i've i've only died okay does that automatically save i've only died when it came to like um i've only died to platformers and not bosses i i haven't died to a single boss yet but i have died to the environment The three hours passed by so fast.
So, oh my gosh, I want to play more, but I should have a lot of stuff to do later today.
But we'll do a longer holo-night stream tomorrow.
But I had so much fun, guys.
I definitely have.
I think tomorrow, definitely will stream a longer holo-night session.
But I hope you guys had a lot of fun watching.
It's been a great start of my holo-night journey.
Sorry if my brain is lagging today.
today my brain is um is very slow today but i'm getting there it takes a long time for my brain to rev up in the morning but it's getting there uh but anyway guys i'm gonna head off now uh and um get some work done today uh but thank you all for coming as always everybody stay hydrated posture check get up and move around to get your blood flowing um is that for me head to bed deserve it.
Yeah, I'm extra birdbring today.
But anyway, guys, I'll see you guys later, guys.
Bye-bye, everyone.
Bye-bye.